welcome to a code report solution video
in this video we're going to be covering
the solution to problem one from the
leak code contest number 176 entitled
count negative numbers in a sorted
matrix
the problem states given an m by n
matrix named grid which is sorted in non
increasing order both row wise and
column wise return the number of
negative
numbers in grid note that you can solve
this using binary searches but the
constraints of this problem are really
really small so with the length of both
of our
rows and columns are going to be between
um 1 and 100
and the values are going to be between
negative 100 and 100 so we can just
brute force this pretty simply and solve
this
a lot faster than utilizing binary
searches so the way that we're going to
solve this problem
is by taking a look at our matrix or our
grid
and here we have a three by three matrix
and you can see in this matrix we have
four negative numbers so the answer that
we want is four and we can get to this
answer by
flattening our 2d table into basically a
one-dimensional structure
and then we can filter all of the
non-negative numbers out and then just
take the length of the count of the
number of
negative numbers in this resulting list
which in this case is going to be four
so
if we take a look at the methods we're
going to need across the 13 different uh
programming languages and solutions that
we're going to look at
um in a table it looks as follows the
flattened method that turns our 2d
structure into a 1d structure
in most languages it's called flatten in
c plus and d
it's called join in kotlin they don't
actually have an explicit flatten but
they have a more general flat map which
you can use
f-sharp you need to use reduce plus the
append binary operation and an elixir
and haskell
it's called concat for the filter method
every single language calls this filter
and for a few of them they actually
bundle a filter overload with their
count and those languages are
ruby d and scala and for the remaining
languages you have to make an explicit
call to sort of a reduction algorithm
that gets you the number of elements in
your list so
a few languages call this count a few
languages call this
length and c plus plus in c plus plus 20
calls this distance but we're actually
going to be hand rolling our own
in order to use it with sort of the
piping syntax so taking a look at our
first solution that's the python
solution
so this is a very non-idiomatic python
solution but
many beginners write their code like
this so we are basically just
initializing
our answer that we're going to return at
the end to zero and then we have a
nested for loop for each row and grid
and for each element in row
we check is it less than zero and if so
we increment
our answer this is what i call the
itm anti-pattern initializing and then
modifying
you typically want to try and avoid this
when you can because
mutation in general is just bad it makes
code
less readable and it exposes more
opportunities for bugs
and this is one two three four five six
lines and the next solution we're going
to look at is a single line that doesn't
use
um any sort of explicit mutation and
modification
per se so the idiomatic python solution
you should use makes his use of
generator expressions
and we basically still have a nested uh
for loops uh but it's
in the gener generator expression syntax
so for j
in grid and for i in j so basically
you're going to look at every single
element
in your 2d grid you're checking
is i less than zero if so that's going
to basically return you a true
and when you do a reduction via the sum
algorithm
on that generator expression you're
going to get the total number of
numbers that are negative so this is
much cleaner than the nested for loop
solution from before
and i highly recommend you try to prefer
to write code like this
moving on to our next solution this is
the ruby solution and this
is extremely nice in my opinion i'm not
a ruby developer this is the first line
of ruby i've ever written in my life
but it's extremely nice so you basically
just call flatten on grid and then call
count on flatten
and count gives you an overload that you
can give it a
unary predicate to do your filter at the
same time as your account so here
you're basically just checking is the
element less than zero and count those
so
super super nice our next solution is
the c plus plus solution we're skipping
straight to the c plus
20 ranges solution because there really
is no nice way to do it
um before c plus plus 20. like you can
solve it but it just doesn't look
nearly as nice as this so here we're
making a call to join
to turn our sort of range of ranges into
a single range
then we're calling filter once again
checking if it's less than zero and then
we're making a call to our hand rolled
length which is just going to give us
the number of elements that are
negative so very nice our next solution
is the d solution
uh somewhat similar to the c plus
solution we first make our call to join
but similar to the ruby and later as
we'll see scala solution we are
making a call to count and passing it a
unary predicate to do our filter at the
same time so quite nice and d has
um stronger typing than c plus so you
have to do an explicit cast in order to
return an integer
at this point our next solution is the
rust solution
always very beautiful here we start with
our grid we turn it
or we make a call to iter in order to be
able to chain these methods afterwards
then we call flatten then we call filter
and then we call count and similar to d
we have strong typing here so we have to
do as i-32
in order to get this to compile our next
solution is kotlin this is the one
solution that doesn't have an explicit
explicit flatten algorithm so we have to
make use of flat map
and in it provide it with this it dot as
iterable
after we've done that we can make a call
to filter and then make a call to count
which is pretty similar to the solutions
we've seen so far the next solution we
have is f
sharp this one also doesn't have an
explicit flattened
algorithm but we can sort of hand roll
one by
making a call to our reduction algorithm
and then providing it with the binary
operation
of list dot append so we're basically
just concatenating all lists together
then we make a call to filter and we
have this nice unary predicate here
and it's pretty cute that they have the
word fun in there to declare a lambda
which i like and then at the end we're
calling list.length
our next solution is the scala solution
this is the last one that
you can bundle the filter with the count
at the same time so
very similar to the ruby solution we saw
dot flatten dot count and then just
providing it with a unitary predicate
and i like the fact that
if you only have a unary function here
that takes a single argument you can
just use the underscore to represent
that variable whereas most other
languages you need to either put
something in pipes
in order to declare what the variable
name in your lambda is going to be
our next solution is the elixir solution
uh this is pretty nice as well
we're making a call to concat and then
to filter and here's our unary predicate
no fun just fn here and you also have to
make sure you provide the end
and then once you've done the filter you
make a call to count next up is haskell
always one of my favorite solutions
it's very clean using the dot free
notation you have to read it bottom to
top so we're doing our concat
then our filter and we have a section
here which is like a terse lambda
which provides a really really readable
and succinct
unary predicate here which i really like
so just parentheses your binary
operation and then you combine the value
to turn that binary operation into a
unary operation
and then once we've done that we just
make a call to length in order to get
the number of negative numbers
next up is our first lisp solution or a
lisp dialect solution and this is
enclosure
so uh here in order to define our
function we go defn
and our function's named count negatives
we pass it a grid as a parameter and
then we can make use of threading
in order to pipe these sort of
algorithms together so we first call
flatten
then we filter on neg int which is
a library provided unary predicate that
you can just make use of so you don't
have to
roll your own lambda and then you make a
call to count after this so this is
pretty nice because threading
enables you to avoid some of the nesting
parentheses that we're going to see in
the next solution
in the racket solution so next up is
racket very similar to
uh the closure solution as these are
both lisp dialects
um so here we're defining our function
name as count negatives and our
parameter is grid
our argument is going to be grid and
then we make three calls one to length
one to filter
here instead of neg int we just have
negative question mark it's really nice
i think in both the list dialects that
predicates are followed by a question
mark makes it very readable
and then the last thing that we're
calling is flat and note that this
is the similar to haskell and that you
need to read it bottom up
because we are nesting these parentheses
so the first thing that's invoked is the
flatten
then the filter and then the length and
last but not least is our apl solution
and this is a language that i've been
learning recently and uh
the thing to note here is that the
solution um or the implementation of the
algorithm is actually shorter than the
algorithm name so
uh what we're doing here is omega is
gonna be our
our parameter which is gonna be the grid
um then we're gonna flatten it with the
ravel
um algorithm which is basically gonna
turn any nested
uh 2d or 3d structure into a
one-dimensional structure
then we're going to apply a unary
operation
less than zero to our one-dimensional
data structure which is called a vector
in apl and that's going to give us a
boolean vector of ones and zeros and
then we're just going to do a plus
reduce which is basically a sum
on uh the ones that corresponded to
negative numbers so
as an example you can imagine we have a
two by two matrix negative two
negative one zero and one and then if we
call
our algorithm on this uh plus reduce
zero
greater than uh ravel mat
you can see the first thing that happens
is we flatten our 2d
matrix into a one-dimensional vector
then we
call the zero greater than unary
operation and this
because this apl is an array programming
language this unary operation applies to
the whole vector
so it turns our negative numbers into
ones and our positive numbers into zeros
and then we just do our plus reduce
which is basically summing up all the
values in this boolean vector which
gives us two
so the last thing to talk about is the
time complexity for all of these
solutions which is going to be
linear in the number of elements in your
matrix or in other words it's going to
be big o of n
times n if n is the length of your rows
and m
is the number of columns as always if
you enjoyed this video and found it
helpful
hit that like button if you want to see
more make sure to hit that subscribe
button
you can follow me on twitter for
reminders 30 minutes before contests
start
and you can find all of the code shown
in my videos on my github page
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next video